Sao bạch, bà trường bú mươi sau bạch ơi, bà phải chỉ bất trang là sai của hãn ngủy mạch.
Bà bà phải bị sau cái biao.
Đây, đi bà cho game road, hình hoàn sổ e bẹ phải.
Đây một trong những lỗi sai tự ki đến thịn nhé khác.
Đây là road, hình xuống e bẹ phải có phải đủy mạch.
Bây giờ mình cảm buộc gà làm như vậy.
Nhà, ý game là bới dụ tiền xuống e bẹ phải đàn y tì game sẽ sẽ được cái dấu bẹ phải.
Khi mà kèm sẽ chế bản tớm một đình bà.
Y nó chỉ có một điều bà bây giờ, tìm mình hai này một thôi.
Nằm cho 1 người ạc nó sẽ mang không, trong khoảng tất cả 1 người 2 người nó sẽ
nhỏ mang không
Đấy trách lại còn nhiều không được, nhưng mà tôi làm nhạc thì thì sẽ mỏ qua cái nhiều kỳ đi
nhạc, và làm tôi lại những cái gì như kỳ không bà như không bà dụng rồi sống